baby Yoda giveth and baby Yoda taketh
away Disney's failure to have toys based
on the mandalorian's baby Yoda available
for the 2019 holiday season resulted in
a loss of up to 2.7 million dollars
because of all the secrecy that was
surrounding the series before it came
out Hasbro was unable to make baby Yoda
merchandise in time for the holidays the
loss was a calculated one though Disney
plus series Creator John Favreau
revealed that he was moved to implore
the house of mouse to keep baby Yoda a
secret up until his reveal at the end of
the mandalorian's first episode he was
inspired by a conversation he had on the
set of Disney's live-action The Lion
King remake with star Donald Glover who
pointed out that these days audiences
are used to knowing pretty much
everything about every hot new property
before it's even available to the public